so if you're looking for a really quick
and easy breakfast idea here's what to
make start by bringing four cups of
water to a boil and then you'll also
need 2 3 cup of slightly warm water and
then once it boils take it off the heat
and add the water to cool it down I'm
using four eggs that are straight from
the fridge gently drop in your eggs and
then cover set a timer for 18 minutes
this will give you a really creamy
delicate egg the yolk is runny and the
whites are kind of like a custard and
then what I like to do is grab some rice
add scallions and then crack an egg add
chili oil and then sesame oil and then
mix that up
then add another egg on top and drizzle
in some key pimeo